the uh remarkably um
talented and hilarious kyle brown of
good morning football and ten
questions of kyle brandt podcast from
ringer and spotify
with guest keegan michael key kyle brand
how are you brother
rich it's awesome to hear your voice it
was awesome to watch you and be part of
what you did
all day on sunday incredible job we
played the
the clip this morning on good morning
football of the cannons going off
we all laughed out loud at the table
amazing moment
well again i mean we're sitting there
and it's gotten you know we got eight
and a half hours to
to go and you know it's kind of like
that sleepy first hour
and uh and all of a sudden we're in the
middle of a segment and they fire those
cannons off and i read throughout the
week
that they would only fire the cannons uh
if the bucks won the super bowl that was
the only time they're not gonna fire him
for every
touchdown every score or whatever and um
and then they fired the kennel i
honestly uh jumped out of my seat like
we all jumped
even though it was across the stadium
and then they did it a second time
and just as ervin was making his point
doing his hype man routine
uh and was one of those where i just
barked at everybody to say
you know can you give somebody a heads
up like what the hell is going on
there's many people in television and
radio who could use the cannons while
they're speaking the energy needs to be
down a little bit
the playmaker doesn't need it it felt
like blasting the cannons during
michael ivan felt like it turning on the
bugles during like a sam
kinnison set in the 80s like we're good
on the energy it was really a lot but it
was awesome tv
so what is your assessment of super bowl
55 three days later
as they're as they're boating in
celebration right now
in tampa as we talk yeah you know i'm
kind of frustrated with civil war 55
all credit in all glory to tempt
buccaneers and i love what they did and
i'm
specifically a huge fan of jason light i
love jason like the gm
and yet it's it was a shocking outcome
31-9
and i'm thinking of some of the more
shocking outcomes we've seen rich over
the past
you know decade or so and i think that
seahawks team just destroying
the peyton manning broncos it was just a
clean butt whooping
um certainly the 18-0 patriots losing
they were
you know we had sean o'hara on the show
this morning part of that giants team
that did it they showed up they were
better they were tougher they were
meaner
i'm i'm my like several days away from
this game with the chiefs
i just feel like that that wasn't the
chiefs we didn't see them and
the postcard of that game honestly i
would that might take away in the the
frozen moment of that game if i could
put it in one image
would be mahomes sprinting backwards
30 yards running around like a rodeo
clown like they've been trying to just
pull magic out of the backside it was
it was ridiculous i it i feel like it
was as if he didn't have a chance and so
i would never put a yeah but permanently
on it or an asterisk or anything like
that but
i just feel like we didn't get the best
chiefs and it was the online injuries
and all that stuff and there were
several other factors but
i feel like we did not get the best the
chiefs best punch that day i wish we
would have
and um it's kind of frustrating me i was
i was happy for a couple days for the
bucks and now i'm like
damn the chiefs really let us down and i
feel like we just didn't get the best
chiefs well i mean
you know and one of the factors that
might have played into it is obviously
what happened with andy reid's son
and britt reed and now being on an
administrative leave and there being a
uh a baby like literally um you know
a little a little human that's on life
support right now and how can
a human being actually focus on a task
at hand when
when all that is going on and that's why
i kind of
regretted the take that i did actually
say yesterday and i'll repeat again
uh with this now as the caveat as well
the
a philadelphia eagles andy reed team
showed up at super bowl 55
where the quarterback that has been
dynamite all year long
has problems either with protection and
balls get dropped and clock management
rears its ugly
head at the end of the first half and
just mistakes get made and it's just
just when you hope that the best can be
put on the field
um it doesn't happen and that's what
happened quite a bit for andy reid in
philadelphia and his tenure in kansas
city
has erased all that and rightfully so um
but that
you know again injuries whatever could
have the officials i thought came out
tight too
um it all did lead to the
a chief's team that we have not seen
look that way since mahome ascended
to the starters role that is true that
happens true
and rich listen i'm glad you brought up
the brit reading there there's no taboo
on that i think there are people who are
low to mention it
or maybe don't really grasp the effect
that that could have on a locker room or
a team
very tight knit team this is not just
that it was
andy reid's son involved it's one of
their coaches it's part of the deal and
it's really disturbing
and i'm not convinced that storyline is
going away and
i'm worried it's not going away and i'm
hoping for the sake of everybody and
praying for the child but i do think it
could play a role
completely and listen
i'm glad you brought up danny reid thing
too because we're quick to forget and
we're eager to forget
that this is 20 years of andy you can't
count him on the big one and that was
his rep and then you get my home and it
all goes away
but as we now kill everything back in
the offseason it's like wow
if they had not completed wasp against
the 49ers
we're still looking at losing the big
one every single time and credit they
made the play but
uh there's a lot to unpack here and as
we do that over the next six months the
thing i have no
time for is the the right on schedule
predictable
blueprint conversation about the kansas
city chiefs they figured it out they did
it now now
we can beat that i don't think so i
think there was a huge set of
circumstances that went into the chiefs
losing that game all of which
had to do with the bucks and injuries
and home field and officiating so
i don't have any time in this offseason
and we have time for anything in the
offseason i don't have time for it the
chiefs are now exposed and this thing's
over i agree with you
i agree with you kyle brand here on the
rich eisen show uh what i don't
understand is why the bucks wouldn't be
considered a favorite to repeat why
wouldn't they be
i mean i i think they're gonna run it
back and
one of the things you already heard was
a guy who uh as he says uh retired from
uh
retiring in gronk and somebody who did
retire
twice once in air quotes from the
steelers and then once literally at his
own choice from the arizona cardinals
and aryans is like damn straight i'm
gonna run it back and we're gonna we're
gonna figure it out jason light is just
money
so let's just figure it out i mean like
they all have that brady mentality of
normally the 43 year old quarterbacks on
his last legs and thinking well i'm
gonna definitely take the opportunity to
ride off in the sunset for my
exclamation point
on my hall of fame career he's like no
absolutely
maybe even 50. you know like george he's
going to he's going to run george blanda
down you know what i mean like that
it's so wild that that so why can't why
wouldn't the bucks be the the favorites
here to repeat he sets the tone and
everything
you you mean you know how this goes
you've done a million of these
interviews where
you ask the question to brady as he's
sitting there with the lombardi and
are you coming back and to a man it's
always
you know right now i'm just thinking
about this one i take some time
in he just goes yeah i'm back he says it
right there
on the and the deus next to nance nobody
does that
and he's so confident so sure and i
think it sets the tone for everybody to
your point b a is coming back rox coming
back
and we'll get into it you know fine
point to me
the champion and a trial by combat that
you know right now to say oh well that's
the team in the nfc
that's just going to be a juggernaut
because i have to tell you i have a lot
of doubts about i know everyone is
already putting rings on matthew
stafford's finger
you guys never won a playoff game in the
rams i don't see these teams around the
nfc they're like
i don't know i'm scared of them afc some
bad bad dudes
nfc the packers never get it done who's
taking out tampa next year
in the this was that they cheated it
rich this was supposed to be the warm-up
year
this is you you get in the wild card and
you yo man you lost 31 to 27
great season next year they really have
something they already won one
they're ahead of the curve and next year
i think they'll be better
i think you we we've stumbled upon
something and you just did there kyle
brent i mean
brady's going to be in his house money
year i mean it's just hot
i mean but also uh you know eight is
much more of a round number than seven
you know
seven's up seven's a prime number
eight's more you know more divisible
you know and the fact is now uh he could
win
as many super bowls uh
as a 40 year old as he did as a 20 year
old i mean
like that these these are all in the
ether and these are all things that you
know he's going to want to
um accomplish so why that's right i mean
brockman recounted where the city where
mo green has no plaque or signpost to
recognize his greatness
thinks that the that the who's who's the
favorite the chiefs are the favorite
followed by green bay and then tampa's
third at 11 to 1. i don't understand it
i don't i don't understand i love rich
that now we've gotten to the point of
trying to hype brady's greatness and
this is why i love that we're involving
prime numbers into this
divisible by themselves and one only i
will double down with you
i don't even look at seven first for him
the number i look at for him is 10 and
i've started 10
super bowl so he gets to it next year
then he's at 11 that's at another prime
number that just doesn't that won't do
i think you have to make it nice and
even and uh
go with your own number and get to 12
which is your jersey i think it's
starting 12
super bowls potentially winning nine of
them that's where i'm at yeah i know
especially since i mean if he wants to
continue on as
uh with his branding which i'm sure he
does tb12
i mean tb12 is is all of that uh and
a biscuit i got uh kyle brown here on
the rich eisen show keegan michael key
is one of the most engaging energetic
funny
people i've ever met and been around i
love talking to him and i can only
imagine the two of you guys must have
hit it off
for your pod this week um amazing i
couldn't agree more
the most articulate person on the planet
earth if i try to talk like him i will
break my jaw
he is so funny and so fast and
we got into the whole thing of a
hangover crinkleberry and all the key
and peel stuff
we we we uh we look back and when he
hosted the nfl honors rich and
it was so time stamped that very that
very moment that night that
he had multiple jokes about uh brock
osweiler's contract
were in the monologue so that let you
know i think it was very 2017
he was incredible that episode that now
and i have to tell you rich just an hour
ago i recorded one of ten questions with
a former number one overall pick
and had an incredible time with alex
smith who wow
great unbelievable listen here alex
smith you sit down you're like i'm gonna
talk to him about
urban meyer jim harbaugh colin
kaepernick patrick mahomes on and on and
on
and uh richie told the story never heard
before about
when he had the one year with my homes
he's sitting there and it's late in the
season and he's running the number one
offense in practice
and everybody starts talking they're
like have you seen what the rookies
doing with the scout team because he's
doing these uh no look passes and he's
going behind his back and this guy's
putting on a show over here
and at that point alex smith is like
yeah i may be playing somewhere else
next year it's an amazing story he's
full of it i like the fascinating guy
i can't wait for that he he's kind of um
you know i i interviewed him when he was
coming out of utah
uh and was in the mix for that's the
first time i interviewed him
um on nfl total access way back
in the day and then my last time i
interviewed him was at the super bowl
in minnesota um when
it was obvious that the chiefs were
going to go to mahomes and he showed up
that day
and i asked him what you know what his
future was and he said he did not know
and within three hours of him leaving he
was uh
with washington he was sent to
washington so he's kind of like my dr
nichols
like i wanted him back because he lied
to me
to my face you know and obviously
there's this is not life and death like
rdu 90 was but he was kind of my dr
nichols
like whenever i hear his voice i'm like
i gotta look at him and of course he's
gonna lie to me he's not gonna sit there
go yeah i'm gonna be trading the next
three hours
because it was all going down that day
and he couldn't have been more
professional answering all the questions
you said richard i i'm in the middle of
this speech
yeah we're sorry you switched the
samples
yeah you falsified your research so
devlin mcgregor can make
pro correct i almost showed up at his at
his introductory press conference
all disheveled and beaten up to break it
up
like in the middle of i almost did it
but i thought better of it and he would
say i'm sorry ladies and gentlemen my
friend richard eisen
doesn't feel well
that is the old remote drop ask him our
poll question for the day
over there all right kyle it's the
anniversary of lynn sanity's start
today obviously one of the greatest
one-hit wonder hoops
players of all time who's the greatest
one-hit wonder
nfl player of all time we went david
tyree
peyton hillis tebow larry brown
oh those are great okay i have a
definitive answer um
i love peyton hillis uh the guys on the
madden cover that's right
larry brown went on to be a big contract
from the raiders
and then who was the swiss c who was the
third one you got uh
tyree tebow hillis obviously the answer
here is tyree in a runaway because the
other guys
had uh albums they released they had
albums you know with the ten tracks and
david tyree was just that the cassette
single it was one song
he never had another catch after that he
now has a smoothie store in new jersey
just one he was a full like right said
fred i'm to say i don't know right that
fred actually had an album
i know i had the cassette single the
rest of those guys they had at least an
lp that they got out a season worth or a
runs worth
i think it is definitely david tyree but
as i heard of them coming in
when you do a poll like that everyone
says wait what about this guy what about
this guy you're forgetting some and i
think they're right
yeah i know he i guess uh he's like that
one
he's the uh that thing you do he's the
wonders you know where he caught
where he caught the ball on top of his
head i know the one i'm getting on our
twitter timeline is timmy smith
from uh from the super bowl you know
that that's the one that i'm getting the
most right now the big one because of
the stage
i i'm trying to think of my top of my
head there was a guy remember
when rogers had was throwing hail mary's
to jeff
janice uh the wide receiver against
arizona that was a big one and there was
one where the patriots had a running
back
i think his name was jonas gray and he
had like
five touchdowns in a prime time game and
then was late to practice the next week
belichick adam and cut them see ya so
that would nominate them yep jonathan
jonas gray against the colts on that
sunday night game
yep it was and then he missed and he
missed the practice because it was a
snowstorm
see ya jonas wouldn't want to be out uh
so uh before i let you go uh kyle brandt
uh we are going to talk between now and
the beginning of the season i
i truly appreciate you calling in every
week man
um it's been a a pleasure literally
right in the middle of the week you help
us get through the hump day
with a laugh and always something to
think about and pop culture and sports i
really appreciate it
um so thank you that's number one thank
you
thank you listen i remember i remember
coming on week one after week one
and uh you had to you had to calm me
down in your sage wisdom and i had
picked the tampa bay buccaneers to go to
the super bowl and they just got their
clock cleaned by the new orleans saints
and i'm sitting here panicking to you
saying
rich i gotta switch my picks that's my
pick you were a steady hand
uh a voice of reason as it were and what
do you know the tampa bay bucks are
literally having a parade today
on cigarette boats like sunny crockett
so thank you for having me i love you i
love your show this is
one of the highlights of my week i'm
dead serious when i say that so much fun
you guys
i appreciate that if i only listened to
myself because i
topped off the box multiple times
including super sunday allowing michael
irvin
to act like he was uh caping for tb12
all 26 weeks
um i had to hold him to account on
yesterday's show for that but uh
right now uh one prediction i'm gonna
ask for you to crystal ball for me
um and then we'll check back in with you
periodically okay uh
the starting quarterback for your
chicago bears in 2021 will be fill in
the blank
what do you got for me okay they can't
possibly bring in next falls again they
can't have him start
i don't think trubisky works out
contractually he's a free agent he's
gonna walk away
i'm gonna take a shot i'm gonna take a
shot
and i'm gonna say that the starting
quarterback
week one for the 2021 chicago bears is
sam darnold
uh you'll love him man
is that a melancholy response no no you
will love him
you will love him that would be great
that means that the jets let me let me
let me extrapolate let me pull on this
strand let me
put more meat on the bones the jets will
give up darnold because they have
drafted somebody or they have acquired
the holy grail from
texas from houston we got i think that
they have made a massively aggressive
move in the draft
and have redone their quarterback
situation uh
for their brand new head coach i don't
think that they're doing the deshaun
watson thing because that's going to be
too messy for too long i think that
they're making an empire move in the
draft with all those picks that they've
built up
okay by the way if you get to sean
watson we discussed it earlier that
that's the
season opener on nbc is bears oh there's
a box if it's right
desean gets his first start with the
bears if he's with them
that would have been thank you for the
call kyle brandt
uh the uh podcast ten questions with
kyle brandt on
ringer and spotify this week's episode
is
keegan michael key and then alex smith
in a future episode
i will be uh i will be listening tuned
in and kyle thanks for the call as
always appreciate anytime rich sometime
in the off season we'll get together
with our drinking buddies
whitman you're the best well
as long as we can find them on the uh on
the island
in the maui sun because that's where i
saw that's what i saw on television so
um thank you for the call you'll be
you're there thanks guys right back at
you
gosh whitman price and a dodd
the running man home game hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here